hey everyone Joey here and we've got
some new gameplay footage from
NetherRealm stream of injustice -
featuring a couple matches between
Wonder Woman and Harley Quinn they're
also showing off Arkham Asylum one of
the new stages in the game but where
else would you like to see the cat's
fight let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for all delays in just as to
coverage I don't don't shake my hand are
we gonna do you see who do you think is
gonna win I have no comment we are
starting ok here we go what you know
what I don't I don't think a button
through the intro ok we leave some ham
oh we took them out when we know what
some of the may be special story stuff
to pop alright perfect
this is everyone's first look at Arkham
Asylum signs which is different for
power characters again or we may be
asleep
basil young and whipping man oh the
railing oh gosh get out now probably
slide in this carrot matchup now the
Harley Bishop repair criminal modifier
here try feel like you decide how
they're going to have to establish
he's also good start no man I'm getting
Oh very decisive
maybe not oh my god he's dropping there
calm I was doing great I am going ham
with down - yeah which is good because I
jump around a lot yeah it's a great in
Thayer mood let's go pick things up a
bit
oh I didn't want to do that go bud Golu
I'd all fight it up tie it up don't know
here you've got an on top of my right
Harley is very very good at regulating
drums nice or one more way that oh the
sign got interrupted no no this line
almost got the combo Oh got a combo uh
not like there anymore this color you're
not using your buff at all oh wow - lady
got two birds that's no good as you can
get in damn number your buck yeah keep
it that's always my forget no you never
know which one you're gonna get no say
what you see we doing oh call it what it
is please I've got over here full
inventories it happens doctor all right
sorry I need a minute to relax did you
want to change your little alright I
think I'm good ok I think the lights dim
on this Lantern Oh we'll get back you
can do it
oh you go down - oh okay goes the throw
pon it is it they need to throw counter
mess once you know the coupons
who what are you get him down a tree is
bad oh my gosh I'm trying to get away
and nothing
Oh too much another decisive for sure
yeah
how about hollows going crazy I popped
him yeah this is the Bobby dude now I
was taking a lot of prizes Alton well
now you trained me I just didn't track
single oh yeah yeah when you first start
playing wonder with you I know I'm going
to the stream and then after a couple
days you really grew to like I say he
might be your favorite treasure because
yeah I like her a lot actually have a
lot of fun
I got a real barnburner situation oh no
no no no making hay with that key one
really is just this on there very fast
hello he is not going to not going to
block love got me not I mean he's not
going to walk period yeah I just don't
believe in it
yeah major props to the animation cable
i every every member of the team though
the round wins are all really cool yes
like they're awesome I didn't use bus
again I keep forgetting to resonate I
need to change my plan I baby oh there
you go this one gives you damage
reduction you will take less damage
while the track very very good
oh no down to City Hall and bound oh no
laughing now bump is already action get
me ducky
oh no jump three okay you know drop them
one cut and there you go it's poison
mystic no combo be a mess the first time
here might win the first run
no no wake up in from again get head up
chin up yes to be a good use of but
interrupting upon even this is a pretty
close don't one even round
Melanson come on the lantern is shining
bright lantern type the guardians are
all watching and judges are judging all
of you in the second half should have
done that
oh that was a very big mistake big
mistake Derrick could be smart is gonna
bet all the regard but Derek's not smart
is he Derrick has an unorthodox style of
reward and cat not very PJs
they're sitting on folder
no no money oh that and that's the
current one mistake just think of it
this way
advantage you're taking a new is he's
not gonna get a clash calm this is very
global the time not if you get sensation
with going up tantrum oh no this is
where all over the corner that's okay
whoa whoa oh yeah woo good match there
you go ah played my best
[Music]